le binz son principe assez simple déjà
ce processus dont aucune façon faire les
choses bon la version officielle
anglaise bunting information modeling
c'est à la base un principe pour
concevoir et construire des bâtiments
qui encore une fois mon humble avis se
fonde sur deux éléments précis pour le
premier temps la collaboration et aussi
sur l'information unix alors que chaque
élément d'un bâtiment représente une
série d'informations qui rattaché à
différents corps de métiers bon
l'exemple plus banal étant probablement
de mur qui bat qui forcément placé par
larchitecte qui peut avoir des fonctions
structurale qui contient des éléments
acoustique par exemple donc le même
élément du bâtiment requis à les ponts
des formations de différents de
différentes parties
ce qui fait que processus très
collaboratif ce qu'on avait à peu près
avant d'avoir pu tout le monde qui
décide et dans son coin qui faisaient
leur plein et puis on l'essayé
d'amalgamé tout sur l'affairé hélas
hélas c'est un peu le contraire donc dès
le départ on essaie d'intégrer tout le
monde on travaille dans une maquette
numérique
donc il faut faire la différence entre
le processus qui est le bim et la
maquette numérique qui est qu'il produit
qu'on va créer donc à partir de certains
outils donc les informations caustique
sont dans la maquette numérique qui
ensuite lui traduit et importé en
fonction de la technologie pour
récupérer l'information dont toujours
cette information unique seraient enfin
l'analyse le nsc une école mais c'est
aussi quelque part un mini usine ce
qu'on retrouve des machines de haute
précision pour les laboratoires de
chercheurs donc le bim a permis de
rentrer ces informations là c'est à dire
qu'on a modélisé un physiquement on a on
a repris les dimensions des machines
à recréer et on les a positionnés dans
la maquette en trois dimensions dans le
site du projet cette facilité de
compréhension permet d'aller plus loin
du coup dans le niveau de conception
jiwok caractérisé le bim
pour moi c'est un outil de communication
un outil de communication très important
parce qu'on est capable de comprendre et
de voir les choses sur de façon
immédiate
on sait pas mettre mal débrouillé
puisque on a reçu le prix du bim d'or
2015 grâce à ce point là s'il doit
caractériser le projet le net c'est
surtout une aventure collective
notamment grâce au boom